[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour again i'm honored to be
able to host these conversations and
stay really honored again and excited to
be able to jump into a conversation
topic that we haven't addressed up to
this point and that's really thinking
about mental health in the military so
today i'm honored to be able to host
three guests for a conversation about
military mental health the military and
the unseen wounds of war
the first guest i'd like to introduce is
stephen elliott
stephen is a veteran of the war in
afghanistan having served there as an
army ranger in 2004 he's also the author
of war story a memoir in which he
details his journey to and from the
battlefield
and the reality of the unseen wounds of
war
it's a really great book very compelling
story and an important narrative which
i've read so i encourage you to check it
out if you haven't read it already
i also did want to mention that steven
is someone who has been featured on espn
npr nbc fox news msnbc and others in the
hope that he and his family's story
would help others also find hope and
healing
he's someone who's a native of kansas
he's currently an entrepreneur and
resides in southern california with his
wife and two daughters and someone i was
able to connect with a few years back
glad that we have this opportunity to
reconnect and want to make sure i
welcome stephen elliott to the aliara
podcast
thanks for having me
of
course the next guest i'd like to
introduce is ellsworth tony williams
tony is someone who is a combat army
veteran having faithfully and honorably
served in active duty in the army for 24
years
eight enlisted and 16 years commissioned
this includes service during desert
storm operation iraqi freedom and
operation enduring freedom he's also
someone who's received numerous awards
including a bronze star and three
meritorious service medals
one thing i really admire about tony is
that after he retired in 2007 he
actually decided to rebrand himself and
get a master's degree in clinical mental
health counseling from troy university
upon graduation he founded and is
currently the president and ceo of
veterans counseling veterans and he
continues in this really important work
i will mention as an aside i watch one
of the recent updates that he did i was
really encouraged by the the energy that
he brought as he was dancing to
pharrell's happy at the beginning of
that update and i thought that that was
great just to be able to lead off in
that way i want to make sure i welcome
tony williams here to the ier podcast
thanks for being here
and the third guest who i'd like to
introduce is dr barbara rothbomb
who is the director of the emory
healthcare veterans program and also the
director of the trauma and anxiety
recovery program at emory she holds
numerous titles and has lots of honorary
titles as well but i did just want to
mention some of her work that she has
also been involved in dr rothbaum is
someone who specializes in research on
the treatment of anxiety disorders
particular ptsd
she's also been able to contribute to
lots of conversations and to
reports around policy as well and has
briefed the department of defense the
veterans association or veterans affairs
the house and senate committees on
veterans affairs and the armed services
committees on the institute of
medicine's report around some of these
topics
dr rothbaum is someone who has been
studying ptsd treatment since 1986 and
she has also developed tested and
disseminated some of the most innovative
and effective treatments available for
ptsd which i'm sure we'll talk about
today
she's also authored numerous scientific
papers has also published over 11 or 11
books the most recent of which is
entitled ptsd for the general public
ptsd what everyone needs to know so
again someone who has a long-standing
long-standing history and effort and
effectiveness in this work and we're
grateful to be able to welcome barbara
to the program today as well
thank you for having me of course
so as my listeners know i always just
like to start out checking in with
everybody to see how everyone is doing
at this moment as we are at the end of
february of 2022
and with everything that we continue to
experience i think it's just helpful to
kind of center our conversation there as
a launching point so i'm gonna go in
reverse order of our introductions and
actually start with barbara
i'm very excited so we've pivoted back
and forth with our veteran program over
covid um at the beginning we went
telemedicine we came back
um with the omicron variant and the
surge in january we went telemedicine
today again this week we've brought
people back in person again so it's just
exciting to have veterans on site again
well that's wonderful to hear i know
that's been quite a journey um and just
from what i've seen from some of the
work you've all done it seems that you
pivoted pretty well in terms of really
getting the message across to let people
know the services were available and
still highly effective but i'm sure it's
exciting to come back in person yeah no
they are and we we gather data on
everything we do and we're so thrilled
that our telemedicine treatment is just
as effective
but it's nice to have people on yeah
definitely agree
tony how about you how are you doing
these days no i wasn't i don't know if
you're going to dance for us as well but
i think you're on mute
i said where's the music playing
i think one thing about because i'm
basically introverted
and this
covid forced me to become more
extroverted with my virtuals so it went
for that you would not have seen me on
so most of the stuff i've done is been
in person which which really is only
people who are there know it exists and
because of the omicron and stuff going
and all that stuff's going on i'm forced
to do all my events virtually which now
has increased to people that see what i
do so that one side of it um i've seen
some positive as far as that reaching
more people and stuff like that and
accessible as a non-profit is definitely
more economical to do it uh virtual
versus these uh these events that are
going on so that's a good thing here i'm
still trying to monitor
how covet and hopefully these guests can
talk about a little bit is how has
covert affected suicide you know it's my
name bread and butter when it comes to
the military and veterans i mean because
you know um i have everything i know is
anecdotal is anecdotal and if you see
some reports that come out from the dod
you've seen something different so i'm
definitely curious to hear from these
guests here have they seen any kind of
differences when it comes to coping
in the veterans space
yeah that's definitely tough but we
should definitely make sure we loop back
to i'm encouraged to hear that you know
in a way the silver lines that you've
been able to expand your reach in some
ways as well so i applaud you for taking
advantage of that and and being flexible
again just in the moment that we're in
as well so
stephen how about you how are you doing
these days
uh doing okay um we had the last couple
years have been certainly what they've
been for for all of our society and you
know we decided to throw in a move from
the seattle area of southern california
just because we thought that'd be fun
um in the midst of all that
and um so yeah it's been a weird the
last couple years have been
um
you know our the problems that we've had
to deal with in our household you know
i'll take those any day over the ones
that a lot of people had to struggle
with so
um i found myself
much more inward focused than i would
like to be just in terms of you know
navigating a move and navigating changes
and enterprises i'm engaged with that
are kind of resolving
and um yeah really grateful i mean our
household is uh is
healthy and um you know we just feel
really fortunate to be where we're at
and um yeah and and i'm excited the
right word but certainly you know ready
to to whatever extent we can you know
continue to re-engage in this
conversation so
um yeah happy to be here
excellent again sounds like a lot of
flexibility and some uh i don't know
what the right word is bravery maybe on
your part moving it in the middle but it
sounds like things are
yeah yeah we started the process prior
to uh covid um and i continued that
process and um
yeah again it's you know you know moving
is what it is but um that's uh
self-imposed and you know we're we're on
the other side of it and right
to be here so yeah that's wonderful to
hear i appreciate you know the way you
put everything in context to even just
acknowledging what challenges you you
have had but also knowing that there are
lots of other things a lot of people
have gone through on clear and i think
that ties into a lot of the stories and
the work that you all do as well um so
before we kind of jump into some of the
you know
the media the conversation so to speak i
also wanted to give you all a chance to
talk about the work and the initiatives
that you're involved in so stephen
actually if you could start out just
telling us a little bit about the
elliott fund and what you all do um as
an organization
yeah um yelling fun was originally
established uh in conjunction with uh
the publishing of war story a few years
ago uh really um there wasn't i'd like
to say there was a a lot of strategic
thought put into it there wasn't
it was simply established to be a
pass-through entity for uh any book
proceeds because that was one of the
things that
for us we felt was important was that if
there was any financial resources that
that book produced we wanted to be able
to channel those to other non-profits
that were doing good work in the
veterans space so really that was that's
all it was initially and then
um you know we've continued to kind of
use that as a platform really of
connection between resources and other
organizations
and right now
the main work that we're doing uh we
being my wife and i and wife brooke
is we're working closely with a film
producer named f dolan who's
in the finishing stages of
post-production for
a documentary film called stranger at
home
that really chronicles the it chronicles
the story of
a military mental health whistleblower
named dr mark russell who's a former
naval commander and who in the early
stages uh you know pre-iraq invasion uh
was
adamantly raising concerns as to the
gaps between the dod stated policy for
mental health and the actual practical
gaps for how that was applied and so um
that documentary which uh we've we've
seen the rough cut of it it's it's um
it's it's pretty compelling um we'll be
using whatever resources we have in our
platform
um to um to advocate both for that film
and for um policy changes within the
active duty component um to to help
curtail the military mental health
epidemic so that's that's kind of what
we're up to right now
that's really encouraging to hear that
you've been able to continue in those
efforts and some of these important
topics i'll be curious you know as we go
through even with some of dr barbour's
experiences to maybe even comment on
some of the things that she's seen in
her perspective as well
before we get there though tony i want
to give you also a chance to talk a
little bit about uh veterans counseling
veterans on the heels of what stephen
has just mentioned as well
oh
so i found the veterans council veterans
in 2014
and um as i actually after i interned at
the veteran uh va and what people don't
understand and don't know it's not a
slide on them but uh 90 of the providers
aren't veterans
and i realized that when i was when i
was getting my interns and and talking
to them so that's why i came up with the
idea of veterans why can't veterans
counsel veterans
and it's a veterans council veteran is a
non-profit that consists of veterans and
spousal veterans who in the mental
profession doesn't matter it's almost
like uh uh it doesn't matter if you're a
clinical psychologist or or or or
lcswmhc
and and so i just want to get away from
identity and try to get away from an
identity of being a social worker and be
more of a veteran that's helpful versus
i'm a social worker or i'm a
psychologist that's to me is what's
breaking we got i wanted to break
through
veteran council veterans is primary
mission is suicide prevention
veteran suicide prevention and we do
this with the model we call team which
is teaching education advocacy
mentorship and services and and and many
arenas and so uh and we try to take the
risk factor and turn into protective
facets one of the things that that that
is different from us is that people
don't understand that don't realize that
over about seven percent of
and the veterans have us have a
relationship one way or the other
okay so we you know you lose that when
you're in the service they get as much
service as you get once you get out of
the service it's just a veteran that
gets all the services so i wanted to
make sure i include them in everything i
do when it comes to that so we focus not
just now on the veteran but we also
focus on the family as well strengthen
the family
and the veteran so those are the things
we have and we'll cover we'll come up
next week we're doing a a veterans
family mental wellness workshop for the
veterans families we're gonna do a
military psychotrauma workshop and we
have a summit as well military veterans
uh suicides some of our fourth one and
it's gonna have faith peers mental
health and and uh and the community you
need all four to have any kind of debt
veteran suicide is a national problem
but it has a local solution you cannot
nationalize it you can't franchise it
you can't monopolize you have to look at
the local community to really fix it you
can't take something like right now one
of my biggest you know concerns is that
whenever you have a crisis you call this
number it's a va number but they're all
in caladega
okay what do i got to call caladega my
house is on fire down the street why do
i call it a fire department in new york
to put my house out
so we got us we got to get away from
that that that thing i'm trying to push
as much as we got to start inviting
involving more of the community when it
comes to suicide prevention intervention
and postmention so that's my that's my
thing thanks so much of course and
thanks so much for that description i
mean it's encouraging and to hear the
holistic approach that you're using as
well um and again just the innovative
concept of veterans counseling veterans
and how you've been able to make
progress in that as well
um barbara also to pivot to you and have
you tell us a little bit about the the
programs that you direct as well if you
could
right so i direct the emory healthcare
veterans program
we are funded by philanthropy and a
large grant from the wounded warrior
project so many many thanks to wwp
we can bring in
host 911 veterans from all around the
country we bring them into our place in
atlanta set them up in a hotel near our
clinic
and we give them a lot of treatment
every day for two weeks it's called an
intensive outpatient program
they get a lot of individual therapy
where they we do evidence-based therapy
so that's therapy that has been shown in
studies to be helpful
we treat ptsd
depression anxiety we've got specific
tracts
for substance use or misuse we've got a
track
for mild traumatic brain injury we've
got interventions for pain
we teach everybody yoga they can have
acupuncture for pain so we we've we've
got family surfaces even before covid we
involve the family via telemedicine
because we really want people to eat
breathe and sleep the program while
they're here
but we involve the family via
telemedicine
and we
everything is at no cost to the veteran
so transportation housing
they get more therapy in two weeks than
most people get in an entire year
and it's effective therapy so i don't
know if people know there's a lot of
dropout from ptsd treatment i mean ptsd
is a disorder of avoidance and that
means therapy too we have a 93
completion rate
so i really i've been treating ptsd my
entire career i think this is the way to
treat it with the iop so every monday
we've got a new cohort of veterans it's
a two-week program so any given time
we've got people that it's their first
weekend their second week so they've got
a cohort of veterans who are also doing
the hard work and they've got our whole
team
we've got psychologists social workers
psychiatrists neuropsychiatrists we've
got veteran outreach coordinators who
got everybody who's trying to help them
and give them evidence-based treatment
so
i'm i'm very proud of it and i'm happy
to talk about it because i think we're
one of the best-kept secrets
in the nation and we don't want to be we
want to be full every time yeah that's
wonderful to hear uh really again
appreciate the work that you've been
doing and it struck me as you've been
talking some of the overlapping themes
between the three of you in terms of the
efforts and the ways that these aren't
narrow efforts in one specific pocket
but just trying to make sure that it
really is something that's broad and
across the board i mean we'll definitely
dig into that a little bit more of that
just actually going to open it up not
planned a little bit of an audible i'm
curious if you all have thoughts as
you've all heard each other talking
about each other's programs and efforts
in a sense either in terms of things
that resonate with you or questions that
you have for each other so i'm going to
leave that i know that's a little wide
open but i'm just curious how you all
have been kind of listening into each
other and processing what you all have
shared well i want to respond when you
know tanya were talking about that we we
have to pay attention to veteran suicide
and agree totally and so ours is a
clinical program but i'm a i'm a
clinical researcher too so we gather
data and we look at it to make sure what
we're doing is working
and with
one of our sister sites we combine data
and we were able to see when you treat
the ptsd effectively the suicidal
thoughts decrease
so it we were we felt that the word we
hear most often it sounds dramatic when
i say it but when we send people back to
their families the word we hear most
often is transformative you know you've
given us you know our tony back
uh you know but
it's uh so my approach is
treat what's wrong i mean but that's
also within our whole holistic and
family approach
and that that's helpful um that's great
too yeah i mean i heard two things you
know um
one from one from each of you which uh
really you know i i completely agree
with uh you know one
um
uh dr rothbaum just talking about ptsd
being a few years away disease a
disorder of avoidance uh i mean that's
essentially um i think that could have
been the subtitle of my story
oh yes uh was that i mean when i looked
at the
the resources that i had on my disposal
um but the the narrative of my own pride
and in my own avoidance in terms of
you know not wanting to
really uh risk hope um
about like what if i put myself out
there and i pursue you know these
various modalities and treatment that i
didn't understand and i was still broken
well then what um that was part of it
but but also then the the piece of you
know not feeling that i even deserve to
be well um and and so i think for me
part of part of what i experienced was
certainly
uh self-inflicted in terms of avoiding
um you know whatever help that there was
uh and then tony something you said
which i
you know totally agree with is uh the
the the grassroots you know up down
approach which which doesn't preclude
professionals or policy makers i mean we
need a web and a net of all sorts of
people within the ecosystem but um but
yeah you're you're 100 right i mean i
don't know there's been a lot of
counseling sessions that have taken
place in bars and probably still do
and maybe that's okay maybe that's
that's maybe not where it needs to
always stay
but um if that's a piece in the journey
then then so be it and i think um you
know that's that's part of it too is
how do you get people that are on that
journey
into a place who are generally people
who are very much motivated by service
in the first place and that's maybe part
of the things that are depressing is now
they feel like they're useless they're
not in uniform they can't do the thing
that was meaningful to society anymore
and now they're thinking about suicide
the fact that you know them helping
others is part of their own healing i
think that's um that's so good and
that's so encouraging
you know uh stephen and i and everybody
one of the things i always when i talk
about the locality and local when you go
to a a community and you ask the best
fried chicken where's the best fried
chicken
people from there most of the time it's
this
cranky old nasty old building
right with everything falling down but
it's a long line right
because the local people know where the
best food is if your ex somebody who's
not from there that's what they're going
to tell you kfc popeyes because it's a
national brand but ptsd i mean ptsd
suicide is so personal you can't get
anything more personal than dying by
suicide and i think that we got to get
past that using the same scale of the
same way of doing things if we want to
really be effective we got to start
looking at people who are in
accessibility uh and and stephen you
were talking about how we
train as and uh kind of you know how we
we train as a military i saw you didn't
say that but that's what i heard
is in the military we strip away your
individuality right
like wax on the dang floor and we put
the you know put the stuff down to take
the wax off and we put in your whole new
identity with the collective we don't do
a good job out reversing that we don't
do a good job of taking that same energy
we put to make you collective to make
you think individual
and so if i was to treat a veteran you
you cannot do it individually because we
don't think like that we think
collectively we think as a patrol we
think it's a squad we think it's a tune
and some of the things that we call
about we call suicide over there is
considered heroic action right so if i'm
walking down and we're in a patrol and i
see an ied or a bomb in the room you
know i want to protect the rest of my
people so i don't think and i go and i
jump on it well no one says suicide
right
because then that's considered heroic
you get a medal and maybe a medal of
honor
but when you take those same things that
are sort of great over there
when you transpose them over here there
are now problems you can no longer being
hypervigilant over there is good right
you never know who's going to take you
anywhere so being high vision looking
who's that by the corner hey you looking
at me this song that's
part of what it takes to survive over
there that you cannot use the same
things you learned that kept you alive
over there over here so
i'm just saying that we got to look at
and i haven't talked to families
it's on the dynamic but as an individual
we cannot keep using the same model of
an individual individual and then try to
think it works for us we weren't trained
that way we were trained like like uh
like the borg on star trek you know we
were trained as the collective the
and that's what we're used to trying to
get part of that collectiveness and not
that individual i want to be rich so i
just thought i wanted to relay that to
when steve was talking about beating at
a bar or some of the most effective
people for suicide is not somebody with
a phd or three thousand letters on end
of the name but it's a regular joe that
sister and say hey man let's talk
yeah
so anyway that's that's my skill with uh
uh my comment when it comes to suicide
um
yeah really well said i appreciate you
pulling out those those nuances uh for
us as well i'm curious for the the other
two as well like how you would um react
to that because it seems that there's
also
this tension between the individual but
you've also all alluded to the
importance of the relationships as well
and the family so
how how have you seen your experience
how do people walk through that
practically still try and get the
attention individually but now within
the context of other relationships not
necessarily in the context of a military
relationship any uh insights or
experiences you all want to share
i can talk for four days about it yeah
i'll try not to um
and i'll focus
in my comments right now on ptsd but i
know we're not just talking about
ptsd i i think
we tend to believe our stories
and if it's something that's associated
with a traumatic event and there's a lot
of avoidance and we don't even want to
think about it we don't want to talk
about it we don't want anything to
remind us of it
then we can't possibly think differently
about it and so what what we do is help
people confront those memories confront
the triggers and do it in a therapeutic
way that then they can take it out and
they can look at it so they might be
thinking
um you know what happened i was you know
jones got killed it was my fault because
i was driving when we hit the ied and if
you can't go there that's what they
carry with them when we work on it they
might be able to change how they think
that
it sucks that jones got killed but as we
went through it i did everything i could
there were eight eyes on the road it was
the insurgent planning that ied
and so once we
can help work them
to have a different perception of
themselves in the world i mean it's kind
of what you guys were saying too and
then that
we translate it completely by involved
in the family by involving other people
to help work on their relationships as
well so it's a
you know i guess it's a chicken and an
egg and you start wherever you start
so a lot of times we'll start with the
individual work and helping people
see it more clearly and then i i think
that can help with some of the
relationships
so it sounds like stepwise in that sense
as well um stephen i'd be curious in
your own experience too because you
alluded to
avoiding the hope in that sense and
because of possible disappointment is
there a way that you
can recall that you were able to make
that transition was it also similarly
focused on you as an individual were
there other
processes or coaches that were helpful
in your situation
well i mean for me it was just a
question of like how bad it'd have to
get before he wanted to get get help you
know and for me it took um the point at
which
you know my wife knew a lot more what
was going on with me than i did um and
it was the point at which
um you know after x number of years
saying
i want a divorce
and then it's at that point you know
which you know that was
13 years ago and we're married and you
know that's that's you know a really you
know blessed part of the story
but at a certain point you just sort of
find yourself sitting in a place that
you never intended to go at no point did
you look at the map and say
yeah i want to go to
moving out and
living with two other single guys after
having been married and having a house
that kind of feels like a step backwards
you know no offense to that but that was
not where i was trying to go and then
you know it took a pretty
yeah it took a pretty thick you know
metaphorical two by four for me
to sort of wake up and realize
maybe if i keep doing or not doing the
same thing
i'm going to keep getting the same thing
and if that's what i want then fine but
if i want a different result in life
then
uh maybe i'm gonna have to try something
else and and i didn't have
i didn't have a you know for me it was
partly a um
it was an absence of context
because i grew up around
a lot of a lot of veterans my
grandfather was a veteran of world war
ii
um you know fought in italy for a year
and a half and it wasn't until i was an
adult that i saw
the other side of the heroic you know
freeing of europe from you know the
germans and realized that you know war
is hell and that was something that he
carried with him for his life and
he had a community around him
but for me like you know post-traumatic
stress disorder was
you know that was um
a scary acronym i didn't know what it
meant um other than uh it meant that
i must be weak
um to be experiencing this
um and that's that's difficult when um
you've come from a military experience
which i think is true for
you know
anybody who joins i don't care if you're
you know a clerk in the air force or if
you're an army ranger or anything in
between
um you join to serve
you want to operate from a place of
strength
and
you have to be willing to to do
difficult things that that some other
people just aren't willing to do
and so
then when you find yourself in a place
um and you know certainly the community
that i served in
um that community self-selects poor
people who just put up with a lot of
pain
that's really what it is i mean it's
it's bizarre it's an all-volunteer
force that we have right now and that
was an all-volunteer unit the only
reason you're there getting yelled at
and being put through the pace is
because you choose to be there
and so then having been self-selected
essentially for
compartmentalizing and focusing and just
accomplishing the task
um
i'm not sure if this you dr rothbaum or
tony who said it but essentially then
it's that deprogramming piece to say
hey it doesn't make any less tough to
acknowledge the fact that you're hurt um
and to acknowledge the fact that hey
it's you know we don't there's no stigma
around that with respect to physical
wounds if i get shot you know nobody's
standing around me on the battlefield
berating me for getting shot
um or making me feel guilty even if i
did something stupid they're gonna care
for me
and so um
that that was certainly a big part of of
my journey um
within my family it was it was it was
essentially how much
how bad do i really want this to get
because it's not going in a good
direction
and
is am i am i willing to risk
which in retrospect the risk was
you know you see it as this big but it's
really
it's a lot of people who want to help
you
and um it's it's
it's so much
bigger in your mind than it is is in
actuality so for me part of that journey
was just having a language and a context
to
not
embrace the trauma and have that become
who i am where then i am that's my sole
identifier is i'm a you know i'm a
wounded veteran of ptsd and that's who i
am that's my business card or something
but it's to say that no that's
integrated into part of my experience
and i can actually experience
growth from that um and i don't have to
be stuck in that place and you know that
growth you know takes a lifetime maybe
but um but that's okay
yeah that's really really well said and
really powerful and appreciate just your
honesty and candor um in that as well um
one thing i mean i have so many things
that came to mind one thing that they
come to mind which i'll have you and the
others respond to as well is just this
it's the aspect of choice and volition
which is a whole big
that's a whole other topic part of the
reason i bring that up though is you
know thinking as a neuroscientist too
and in terms of what we know about what
happens to the brain during certain
situations and how it can change things
and people can get stuck in a certain
mindset and then also thinking about
some of the different episodes that
we've had particularly talking about um
mental health
needs in youth and things like that and
some of the advice from our clinical
psychology experts have talked about
just being there for people but not
pushing people to say you have to get
help but knowing that you are there to
support them so i'm curious you know
stephen with everything that you've
mentioned and the others as well how
people especially in military circles
and veteran circles try to navigate that
aspect of seeing someone who you want to
be able to help to move forward but then
also knowing that steven as you
mentioned you had to get to a place
where in a sense you desired to move
forward and it got bad enough
metaphorical two by four to say okay
this isn't a situation that i want to
go down the road and just stay in that
place at the same time this is probably
my neuroscience framework coming to
knowing that there's so much that
happens in the brain that keeps certain
patterns
happening as well so i don't know if i'm
following this question well but just
trying to get a sense of how
how you navigate
that in the in your own life and in the
lives of those that you love as well not
push people into treatment per se but
also
encourage and try and make that come
about so you all are probably going to
articulate that a lot better than i just
asked the question but just just that
thought that came to mind
well imagine we'll have different
answers so
a lot of times and and our whole program
is set up to try to break down the
barriers to care
um but a lot of it i mean
people are saying how can treatment help
you can't change what happened and
that's what i'm suffering from now is
what happened and so you know part of it
from my point of view is education and
letting people know that
yeah it is
it sucks what happened but what you're
suffering from now is whatever you know
we'll name it you know and got to
diagnose it or
talk about it you know if it's ptsd or
depression or substance use disorder and
that we can treat
um and so letting people know that
treatment really does help
and
you guys are the best messengers we have
i mean people who've graduated from our
program they're our best pr to tell
other veterans you got to do this it
helped and you know steven like you most
of our
folk i don't know if it's most a lot of
them
are there because their wives or
husbands are saying you got to get help
or i'm out of here or sometimes moms and
dads you're not the same person that you
were you got to do something different
yeah
yeah i i can tell you um my wife's a
retired law enforcement officer
and she's the reason why i got into
counseling because she was in charge of
domestic violence
peace
and i bring that because you know it's
it's uh i know we keep talking about
ptsd repeat it's just one it's just one
piece it's not the veteran a lot of
veterans who die by suicide and that
kind of stuff it's not the top three
it's not you know it's it's
relationships it's uh other stuff um so
so we're focused on ptsd there's a lot
more that that encompasses if it's
suicide pj is just one of them
and
it starts with the trust fact and it's
so important that we when we have all
these studies
the number one
factor is the therapeutic alliance
do they trust you
do they feel you care about them
do you think you share the same belief
that they they care that they have
and that's the challenge of when the
frederick county veterans come better
generally speaking we already come with
the trust factor
right when we sit down and talk i don't
have to sit there it's no different to
being african-american if i'm having the
george floyd thing
who do i think is going to more
understand the george floyd thing you
know and that's just the way we are
we're humans we're not robots we're
going to go to something that we're
naturally my tribe actually my tribe
does not have to look like me they just
have to believe like
and then we learn that in the military
so it's that trust factor
and because i know there's more uh than
just the individual even with all the
programs if the family's part of it if
you don't adjust the family then you
really let's you know you can go be
intensive care intensive treatment and
have great your blood pressure's great
eating great everything's great you go
home your wife marks puerto rican
you go home and guess what you're right
back to that bad food because we didn't
do anything
to the other part that you go back to
and that's the same thing with stressful
and all that kind of stuff that the the
holistic piece of so i try so when i
talk to the veteran i hey i look at me
being like a walmart i'm not there to
sit there and solve your problem i'm
there to point to you to the hour
you got a headache
al-6 go the pain g6 right you then make
the decision which one
talks to you
i'm not going to tell you this is the
best medicine i'm going to say go to out
and then you decide when you look at all
the medicines
which one is that you feel is the pain
you want to try to get you know six
seconds
whatever that thing is so we gotta be
more to me and uh we gotta for me from a
non-profit point of view i'm not the
solution
the other there's so many other kinds of
solutions that may not may not work and
that's the same thing i'm bringing on
here cause i'm here you know that the uh
different cultures hispanic cultures
have a different you know they are
really really involved in the family
and and and if your family not part of
that solution you're really only
shooting a piece of that solution and if
you're not and if you don't understand
the language you really gotta problem
because now you're trying to translate
to the to the
to the family who only speaks because
you learn when you get to the second you
know when you get past the veteran you
also english language start getting kind
of almost gone
but you still got to find a way to get
if you want to really treat them so
these are things that i try to fake uh
and and i say i'm just i'm using that
part that everybody understands but as
steven understands that other the
nuances stephen was in a range of time
okay those are bad asses okay
they have a totally different mentality
than a clerk
that's counting beans and bullets okay
he gets rewarded for compartmentalizing
and and and the cognitive cognitive
right he gets rewarded if you're a
commander and i was a commander i was a
commander and i felt you were going to
jeopardize my mission i don't i don't
have any social
determinants that's i don't care about
what it looks like i care about the
mission if i feel like you're going to
jeopardize a mission you're not going
because the mission is number one
if you're arrangers special forces those
guys that's like embracing them
if you're
but if you're a different kind of the
force again uh the clerk the the um the
medics the medics they don't they're not
they're not kicked down to kick doors
down and snipers and everything else
they're about serving and helping people
they just want to help
so that's where a lot of the moral
injury comes up as well because if your
whole being and belief is about helping
people and then you see either you can't
save that person they just got that was
killed or whatever or if you see
a family get taken out by the ied we
don't even talk about the effects of the
you know i'm always militant
intelligence so when you sit there and
you take a bomb and you take out the
whole grid square
that's a whole bunch of generations you
just took out how you dealing with that
what are we doing to deal with that that
piece and that's where the moral injury
that barbara was kind of talking about
in steve there's a more injury piece
again my point is that
we it's too personal to do a study and
you look at the study and you only got
ten percent of the study it has one part
of the population you know if i was to
do the same study and i had the opposite
and i said that hey i got a medicine is
going to work but it only works 90 for
african americans 10 we don't know would
that be evidence-based probably not
but the reverse that's just reality
so i so when i look i look at it i look
at the the counseling in two phases the
military and it's nuanced but then the
other other cultures as well that's what
we got to deal with we started
counseling not just you being a veteran
being a special operator or whatever but
then if you happen to be hispanic indian
uh
female veteran military all that that
are also all a factor that may take more
than just a one or two weeks intensive
outpatient treatment so i'm just don't
add that i'm just trying to let you know
that it's not that simple yeah people to
make it out to me
so anyway yeah sorry no that's great
that's great see if anything you want to
react to there
yeah i mean i i
agree with all that i mean i think it um
i mean it's it's certainly multifaceted
it's certainly unique to the individual
and
the the context that they bring to the
service you know if you're if you're
coming which you know i
i certainly wouldn't characterize myself
as
having lived a traumatized life prior to
the military i lived a very blessed life
but you get to basic training there's a
lot of people there who you know it's
like why are you here just like while i
was a drug addict i figured i wanted
this would be a place to clean out like
seriously
and so
um and they're great guys they're
they're they're good people within that
structure
but then it begs the question well what
the then the weight that is put
on your military service is a weight
that no organization should bear
because all it takes is one bad squad
leader all it takes is one ied all it
takes is one thing which
the military and or war will throw at
you
to then demolish your identity demolish
your purpose
and then just make whatever
you you didn't deal with or didn't even
know you had to deal with coming into
the military it just exacerbates that
and um i think it's i mean i guess
two other short thoughts one is it's
amazing the mental gymnastics that we
can go through to
effectively justify the fact that we
shouldn't be wounded um
the again
the supply clerk and the fob
who uh never went outside the wire
uh but sees you know
dead soldiers being pulled off the
blackhawk
and that devastates them
and they feel
guilty simultaneously wounded because
they've just been presented with
something that we were not designed for
which was war and death
simultaneously with the guilt of the
fact that here i am not even getting
shot at
i don't even deserve to have whatever it
is that i'm feeling and then it's stuff
and then you go to the guy who's taking
his buddy off the helicopter
who essentially says kind of the same
thing which is well this is my job
i'm still alive um jones isn't what
right do i have to feel poorly about
that
and so um
and i think a lot of that comes back to
um it comes back to decades
within the military decades of a broken
cultural narrative
um that um
you you have people don't have a context
for it command structures don't have a
context for it they're scared to death
of it um
for for some reasons that are good right
you you're trying to feel the force to
go to war
and i don't have time to talk about
people's feelings i'm sorry and if if if
that's
that's what so so you get this binary
response which is either
um stigma laden
you're having a hard time therefore
you're not fit to deploy
that doesn't work
um or
it's
nothing to see here
we're all good
and then those things mount and they
build and then you see the op tempo that
many people
across the force
have been asked to endure over the last
20 years and it's staggering the amount
of time that people have spent in iraq
in afghanistan
is just incredible
um and so that's something that we've
never experienced um you know in in
america to that degree as far as um that
level and that duration
of of of combat exposure um in war and
so i think it is a cultural problem i
think it's a storytelling problem
um and having space to tell stories and
just connect dots
um to be able to realize that oh like
i'm you're you know yeah what you went
through
wherever um in afghanistan iraq you know
vietnam
um your house where you were molested or
whatever the issue is what you went
through is absolute 100 unique to you
and your set of circumstances and who
you are as a person um that that's a
unique story
and
good news it's not unique
good news is there's so many people
who've experienced that and navigated
that and some of those people are people
who you look up to and admire who for
whatever reason
um you know you just never had the
opportunity to hear the darkness of
their story um and i experienced that a
lot you know as i was
you know coming back
just people who you know i saw
one facet of their military servants
just like oh you flew cobras in vietnam
wow
wow you were
you were on the beaches of anzia wow and
then
now that i'm not some 16 year old kid
anymore
now that i myself have been to war and
come home
i get a whole another facet of their
story
and i get to see oh wow
there's a whole nother dynamic that
it wasn't just
went to war
dust off your uniform come back and you
know enter society as a fully
functioning adult
there's a lot more often times to that
and so i think the more that those
stories are told and the more that we
can get back to
changing
climates and changing cultures around
that story at the point of woundedness
so that it's not a binary response it's
not either you're on the bench
or you're 100 fit to go face america's
enemies um we do that with the physical
wounds pretty well um and and so that's
uh
that that's a that's something that we
have to learn to do a lot better but but
but it's cultural and i think it's
really you know being able to hear and
tell tell our stories yeah yeah i really
appreciate the way you unpack that and
just
piggybacking off of what the others had
said too i mean so many
aspects of ways that things have to be
personalized both but barbara and what
tony mentioned but then also just like
how he responds in those situations too
um and just it seems there's not a lot
of gray
saving what you're saying too as one or
the other and as tony mentioned
sometimes for a good reason i think as
you mentioned as well but sometimes also
for poor and detrimental a reason so i
appreciate the way you all pulled those
those things out
our time is going quickly this would
probably go a whole another hour but i
did want to give a chance and steven
universe started to go there already
just to give you all time to actually
talk about how do we move things forward
um barbara i know you've done a lot of
work um some reports and testimonies and
things like that too this policy this
culture that needs to shift there's the
way that veterans can continue to
counsel veterans as tony has talked
about but if you all could just share
what your thoughts are and your goals in
terms of moving things forward so we
don't just kind of get stuck in this
cycle and not to i mean that is a theme
that we've talked about already but even
in this cycle of some of the challenges
that already exist in the military and
for veterans um so barbara maybe if you
want to lead off with that sure and i
mean and there's so many ways we need to
move forward so you know what you were
talking about steven a lot of the stigma
and trying to
let people know it's not a weakness i
mean we see it as a form of resilience
to go get treatment and to work on it
and to
so you know trying to
deal with the stigma
obviously i'm working on
treatments not every treatment works for
everybody for sure
and so trying to figure out new
treatments trying to figure out
um so personalized medicine and
biomarkers and all of that to try to
figure out what's going to work for whom
and we're trying to come up with so for
example we do a lot of exposure therapy
and it works very well but not for
everyone so we're working on
augmentation approaches trying to
identify early on i mean we can pretty
much figure
by friday of the first week we can tell
if somebody's on the trajectory to get
the full response or not so we're doing
some different things in the second week
to try to boost that response so you
know i'm going to be a lot on the
treatment front but i think we need to
do it all because our treatments we know
the very best treatments in the world
and if people won't come forward and say
i need help can you help me
then they're not going to help anyone so
we've got to work on all of it yeah
really well said
stephen maybe too i'll follow up on what
you're already starting to allude to but
anything that you want to add in terms
of how we move move things forward
yeah i mean i think you know i think
it's multifaceted i think you know
there's not
you know certainly not you know one
single um
objective or one single um initiative i
think it's i mean it's that's for the
for me these conversations are super
encouraging because it pulls me out of
my own little bubble and and this
reminds me that there's
you know for all the things wrong with
our systems um you know
uh i have a system to even complain
about which wasn't in place 30 years ago
right and it's not in place for
civilians in many cases um so um you
know that was a realization i had some
time ago
where it was
you know whatever whatever
administrative friction there was and
you know seeing a counselor doing
whatever it was it's just like you know
what there's a lot of people who've
probably seen more violence in america
than you saw in afghanistan who don't
even have a dysfunctional bureaucracy to
turn to and so first off
to the extent you can count your
blessings
um and then you know depending on where
you're at in the world you know what can
you do about it and
i think the the piece that we're focused
on that we feel like you know where to
engage in um is really that um that
policy reform uh within the active duty
component um in terms of how do we
um normalize the fact that um
war is not good for the soul and that
there's unseen wounds that the sooner we
address them and not just
force people to stuff them for in some
cases 20 years so that they don't miss
promotion or they don't miss deployment
and then have to deal with it um that's
that's criminal in my mind and it's it's
stupid
um and so
um that's that's a lot of what
you know our advocacy um in conjunction
with storytelling uh is is to try and
move the needle from a policy
level and within the dod
um to um stop weaponizing stigma um to
um change policies and change culture
that can actually be influential
at the point of woundedness and not you
know years after the fact
um
you know there was um there was a film
made i think i think one of the most
instructive things culturally is there
was a film made that some of you may be
aware of um
by john houston in world war ii called
let there be light
um and you can watch that film i think
on netflix i think installment platform
but in that film um he tells the story
of of this uh essentially a field
hospital that was set up i think was in
long island um for folks coming back
from you know the pacific in europe who
are experiencing acute trauma um from uh
from their experiences
and you watch in 50 minutes in black and
white you watch
these these folks um
have those wounds acknowledged um and
you see
what
what how they change in two or three
weeks before we send them back to their
home
and it's um it's powerful and it's not
to say that those are the those
modalities of treatment um or maybe
crude um but just having those wounds
acknowledged within a cohort like you
talked about tony within community
before just being unleashed back in the
civilian world is so essential
the night that that film was to be
screened the dod paid for it the night
that that film was to be screened at the
museum of modern art in new york it was
confiscated by mps and it was classified
until the carter administration wow
nobody saw it
until it was declassified and that film
which was honest and it was hope filled
was replaced by another dod film called
shades of grey
which essentially the message was
if you're a good red-blooded american
you really shouldn't have a problem you
know meeting the communist war dead-on
it's very difficult to watch it's
pandering
it's ignorant it's insulting frankly
it's almost cartoonish
but all that to say is
whether that was explicit or not um that
was a film that was made out of a lot of
fear based on
the next threat that we saw towards our
nation
and that
that idea permeates
so for for us it's
you know you don't fix that
with one movie or one book or one
conversation
but how do you engage to to shift that
narrative back to something that maybe
is hard to look at both at an individual
and a societal level because there's a
lot of failure and there's a lot of
regret
um but there's also a lot of hope
and so um so really that's um that's
where we feel like you know we can
engage is in that storytelling dynamic
and hopefully moving needle um with
national policy change knowing that
if all of our hope is based on congress
changing policy we're in bad shape and
so um you know the work um of you know
dr rothbaum and tony and others in the
community day in and day out is
absolutely essential like that's so
encouraging because that doesn't take
congress getting its act together we can
do that right now in our communities and
so that's super encouraging to me
thanks so much for sharing all that i
mean that's well that story that you
shared about the films that's
well i'm still
i mean just the impacts of that it also
makes me think that we need to do more
to highlight um what dr rothman is doing
as well
if we can summon as you mentioned in the
beginning because i mean that sounds
like it was also part of that first film
that was just not let out and just the
power of that and dr ralph what we
talked about from the effectiveness so
stephen thanks for pulling out those uh
those nuances and just being frank about
you know the realities in a lot of ways
yeah but also highlighting a message of
hope because i do think that that's what
we need to put out there is a message of
hope
100 agreed
tony you get the last word
being a military guy and probably nco
it's not it's not let's don't talk about
don't let's don't talk about let's be
about it
and the thing is i want as far as policy
i want to i want to replicate what the
dod has and rep and put it on the
veterans world so that includes families
well i have this family thing okay that
includes family we got to take what what
worked in the dod world and replicate it
in in the in the and it's going to take
grassroots okay so that's that's fine
with me if i got to start it fine but i
think we got to start looking at not
just a veteran as being the person you
look at but look at the family as well
because sometimes you want gun safety go
to the spouse and they'll they'll be
more likely to accept gun safety than
the veteran all right but we just stuck
on the veteran we're trying to convince
him that oh no it's good for you
so policy on that that i keep talking
about also about
the locality being local local local we
cannot nationalize we cannot
can
monopolize
franchise this okay you gotta you gotta
start with the local community and
that's where your funding has to be okay
so the funding just can't come from one
source and then you try and you have
like one or two people
covering the whole state of florida to
try to do some kind of outreach you got
to start bringing in the community
because the community is them we are no
longer people don't understand that when
you're a veteran you're no longer
federalized so when you have when you
try to do something to me you better
make sure you do the same thing to
anybody else's american citizen and i'm
a dod i'm a federal employee but as a
veteran i'm an individual so if you're
not gonna take their guns away you're
not gonna take my guns away i'm just
saying what i hear i'm not saying that
i'm just saying don't say i am not a
federal piece of property i'm a
constituent so treat us like
constituents of your community that
means the county
the state the city and the state and
federal all have to play a part in
taking care of me not just a federal
government so that's those are the
things that i know and when i mentioned
with stephen i agree with that when it
comes he's a policy guy i think we have
a problem with congress right now
because of two the two partisan so it's
got to start here at the grassroot where
everybody's going to take care of the
veteran you know and finally
when i see a a battlefield political
bodies
i don't sit there and start looking at
the percentages of who's out there okay
i just see a veteran out there that's
laying out and eating hurt needing
needing care i don't see if it's a
female i don't see if it's
african-american i just see a veteran
out there that needs help we need to
bring that down to us
eventually where we also see a veteran
out there that needs help versus
these little these little
things they they put us into that you
know to try to put us in a box so that
those are my my two thing is spend more
money to the community don't forget the
families
from because of policies that's me
be about it don't not just talk about it
but be about it yeah yeah
exactly
well i know we did talk about hope and
for me just having this conversation
gives me hopeless fault i mean in
multiple ways just how frank you've all
have been about the challenges but then
also the ways that things have moved
forward and the ways we can continue to
move things forward um it's also i'm
grateful that even this conversation is
encouraging to you all as you're seeing
different pockets of the work um that's
being done so again i'm honored that
i've been able to you know host this
conversation to be able to uh step into
this community if only for a brief
moment but hopefully not for a fleeting
moment and something that we can all
continue to be engaged in again grateful
to all of you for being here for the
work that you all are doing continue to
do and just for the impact it's having
so many lives
thank you
thank you and thank you for helping us
get the word out of course
[Music]
you